[موسيقى]
يوسف يقول ذلك لكن لا بشائر طيبه يحملها
العام الجديد للحالمين بتحصل اقتصاد
العالمي للاسف هذا ما تجمع عليه تقديرات
خبراء ومؤسسات اقتصاديه دوليه تتوقع ان
يكون هذا العام اصعب من سابقه سواء لاصحاب
الاعمال
فقط الى سد احتياجاتهم الاساسيه شعوب
عديده انه من ارتفاعات القياسيه في اسعار
السلع والخدمه وما في ايدي الناس من اموال
فقد قيمته ولم يعد له باحتياجاتهم وهذا
ببساطه ترجمه لموجه تضخم عالميه للاسوء
منذ عقود يرجعها خبراء الى ارتفاع تكاليف
الانتاج الاسئله التوريد وارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه والغذاء بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
في قصتنا الليله العرب والتضخم العالمي
نحاول الاقتراب من هذه الازمه التي تهز
الاقتصاد العالمي نتلمس اسبابها
وتداعياتها اثارها على الناس في الو متحده
والسودان والاردن وكيف فرضت عليهم التخلي
عن بعض احتياجاتهم الاساسيه نتيجه ارتفاع
الاسعار نكشف تاثير التضخم على النشاط
الاقتصادي وشراء المستلزمات العمل سواء في
الزراعه او غيرها اما بقيه القصه
فنستكملوها مع ضيفنا الدكتور جواد العناني
نائب رئيس الوزراء الاردني لشؤون
الاقتصاديه سابقا ومصطفى يوسف الباحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي ومدير المركز الدولي
لدراسات التنمويه والاستراتيجيه نسال
ضيفنا الكريمين عن التحديات التي تواجه
الاقتصاد العالمي خلال هذا العام الجديد
ومن المخاطر المترتبه على استمرار ازمه
التضخم العالميه وتاثيرها على سياسه
الحكومه العربيه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
وكيف ستتاثر الطبقات الفقيره والمتوسطه
والمتغيرات الاقتصاديه العالميه
والفرسائل المتاحه لتعامل معها عربيا لكن
انه يشاهد الله يبارك لك القصه ونبدا
الحوار
بتجيب لي 15 كيلو سكر لتزيد عليها الان ما
بتجيبها الكيلو واحد
15 ليره بعدين 20 وبعدين 60 بعدين 100
بعدين 110
يعني عشر دنانير قبل سنتين تشتري يعني زيت
ارز الان العشر دنانير يمكن يجيب لك منتج
واحد من اللي انا ذكرتهم الان
دقيق ترتفع بحوالي نسبه 100%
[موسيقى]
للاسعار خلال فتره زمنيه معينه تعد
الطريقه الاكثر شيوعا لرصد التضخم مقارنه
اسعار سله من السلع والخدمات على اساس
شهري وسنويا تحوي سله مثلا مجموعه من
السلع والخدمات الاكثر استهلاكا كالاغيه
والملابس والاتصالات والمواصلات والطاقه
وغيرها تمثل الزياده في سعر السله بين
فتره واخرى مفهوم التضخم وهو ما يعني
تراجع القدره الشرائيه للوحده النقديه
وبالتالي الحاجه الى نقود اكثر لشراء نفس
السله
سبيسي
تستخدمها تفقد فجاه بعد قيمتها وهذا يحصل
عندما تشتري اليوم سلعه بقيمه 10 دولارات
ثم بعد عده اشهر ترتفع الاسعار وبالتالي
لم يعد سعره هذه السلعه عشره بل اصبح 11
دولار
ارتفاع اسعار
خدمته وبالتالي دائره مفرغه من الارتفاع
للتضخم عده مستويات ترتبط بسرعه ارتفاع
الاسعار وعاده ما يكون معدل التضخم الامثل
عند حوالي اثنين بالمائه ومن انواعه
التضخم الاساسيه المتمثل بارتفاع كل شيء
باستثناء الغذاء والطاقه والزاحف الذي
يحدث عندما ترتفع الاسعار بنسبه ثلاثه
بالمئه سنويا اضافه للمتسارع الذي يحدث
عند ارتفاع الاسعار بين ثلاثه وعشره
بالمئه سنويا وعندما ترتفع اكثر من 10%
سنويا يسمى التضخم جامحا اما المفرط في
يحدث عند ارتفاع الاسعار لاكثر من 50
بالمئه شهريه ويحدد نوع التضخم ايضا
باسبابه ارتفاع تكاليف الانتاج او ارتفاع
الطلب او ارتفاع الاجور ويؤدي الحصار
الاقتصادي والحروب والازمات الاقتصاديه
وبعض السياسات النقديه الى حدوث نوبات
تضخميه كما حصل بعد الحرب الكوريه وصدمه
وقف تصدير النفط العربي
بدايه عام 2022 سجلت البيانات الاقتصاديه
العالميه قفزه في معدلات التضخم طالت
اقتصادات الكبرى واقتصادات ناشئه كمثرى
التي ارتفع فيها معدل التضخم ل
14.9% لشهر ابريل 2022 و ستتحذيرات اطلقها
البنك الدولي بان الاسعار قد تبقى عند
مستويات قياسيه حتى نهايه العام 2024
ويحدد صندوق النقد الدولي عده محركات
الرئيسيه للتضخم العالمي والعالمي الحالي
تتمثل في اختناقات سلاسل التوريد وارتفاع
تكاليف الانتاج وسياسات التحفيز الكلي بعد
الجارحه وارتفاع طلب بعض السلع امام نقص
في الارض وانخفاض في القوه العامله
وارتفاع اسعار الطاقه والغذاء الناجمه
بشكل اساسي عن الحرب على اوكرانيا
واغلاقات كورونا
يحدث التضخم نتيجه عده اسباب تضخم من جانب
العرض يعني تضخم تكاليف خاصه اسعار تكاليف
السلعه الاساسيه التي لا غنى عنها اما
تضخم من جانب الطلب فهو نتيجه ارتفاع
القوه الشرائيه وهذا يكون النتيجه لطبع
البنوك المركزيه المزيد من النقود وهذا
حدث بالفعل اثناء فتره كورونا النوع
الثالث وهو التضخم المستورد وهو عندما
توجد دول دوله تستورد سلعه بعينها او
مجموعه سلع من دول تعاني اما من ازمات
سياسيه ازمات حروب او اختلال في سلاسل
الامداد التضخم الذي تعانيه معظم الدول
العربيه الان هو تضخم مستورد هو محصله
لظروف عالميه مختلفه
بمجرد اغراق السوق بالمال سترى نوعان اخر
من التضخم لان المال يفقد قيمته بوجود
الكثير منه وهذا ما تراه في لبنان على
سبيل المثال
مع نهايه عام 2021 بدا العالم يتعافى من
اثار جائعه كورونا لكن اندلاع الحرب في
اوكرانيا
الى مستويات قياسيه وفق ارقام الامم
المتحده
[موسيقى]
من ربع تجاره الحبوب العالميه و80 بالمئه
من صادرات دوار الشمس وهذا ما دفع الامم
المتحده لاطلاق تحذيرات من توسع رقعه
المجاعات حول العالم
فيفا وقعت بيسالوا الناس لماذا ترتفع
اسعار عندما اكون بعيدا عما يحدث في
اوكرانيا وكل المشاكل هنا هذا ببساطه لانه
في عصر العولمه كل شيء مرتبط ببعضها سنشهد
ضغوطا تضخميه قادمه من تلك المنطقه لان
الناس لا يريدون تجاره مع روسيا بعد الان
ولا يريدون شراء نفضيهم لا يوجد قمح قادم
من اوكرانيا وتداعيات حرب اوكرانيا يمكن
ان تستمر لفتره اطول من الحرب نفسها
نعم حتى دعايات حرب اوكرانيا يمكن ان
تستمر لفتره طويله المؤثر الاول هو حاله
عدم اليقين العالمي حيث عدم اليقين تؤثر
سلبيا على اسعار البروستات في العالم
بمعنى انني ان معظم الدول ومعظم البورصه
لا تعرف على وجه اليقين حتى لو امتلكت
الاموال هل يمكن ان تحصل غدا على ما تريد
من سلع حاله عدم اليقين يؤدي الى تزايد
كبير في الاسعار نتيجه تكالب وتدافع الدول
نحو الشراء للتخزين وليس حتى للوفاء
باحتياجات الاستهلاك المحل
تتبعنا واقعه تضخم في ثلاث دول مختلفه حول
العالم هي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والاردن والسودان كامثله لرصد تاثيرات هذه
الظاهره على جيوب الناس
في السودان بلغ معدل التضخم اعلى مستوى
بين الدول العربيه بنسبه 263 خلال شهر
مارس 2022
انعكس التضخم في اجور النقل واسعار السلع
الغذائيه والاسمده بالاضافه لاسعار الوقود
التي تصاعدت بشكل غير مسبوق
[موسيقى]
مشكله الاسمده مشكله المبيدات الحشريه
كلهم الكلام ده بياثر علينا
تضخم بدايه 2019 كاندي 57% لكن بعد تبني
الحكومه الانتقاليه برنامج
وصفوا لينا صندوق النقد الدولي ارتفعت
وتيره التضخم بصوره فلكيه لدرجه انه مثلا
متوسط التضخم كان في 2020 لكل العام 163
بعد اجازه موازنه 20 21 ملي كان موازنه
حصل فيها تعوين همم
الدولار حصل فيها زياده في رفع دعومات عن
الوقود وعن همم ارتفع تضخم الى بلد
422% اللي هو ده قيمه التضخم على مدى
تاريخ السودان الحديث
بعد عملي انا كنت بوفر وبشغل معي يمكن في
اليوم اكثر مني 15 عاما يعني ممكن
اخذت عربيه واخذتها
مساحه
والانتاج كان عالي والاسماك قاعه كويسه هم
من 2019 يعني انا وانت خذار جيد جدا لكن
ما ضغط
التقارير بتاعه
التقاعد
اقل لك
[موسيقى]
اثنين كيلو ونص قبل ثلاثه سنوات 2019
الحياه اللي بتجيني امبارح المبيد الحجري
بالتالي احنا كل الحكومه مفترض تاخذ يده
على الشجره
المبيدات تورده على سن ان احنا نقدر ما
يكون في زياده في الازعاج جديد
من السودان الى الاردن الذي يشهدوا
ارتفاعا في معدل التضخم السنوي تجاوز
اثنين فاصله 47% في شهر مارس 2020 برغم
ثبات قيمه الدينار الاردني امام العمولات
الاجنبيه
بعض الامور حتى نواكب هذا التضخم
تقارير المحليه
في اسعار السلع الاساسيه كالخضراوات
والبخول والزيوت المواد الخام المستورده
ويعزو خبراء اقتصاديون هذا الارتفاع
الاضطرابات سلاسل التوليد العالميه الى
جانب الحرب في اوكرانيا من جهتها ولمواجهه
ازمه التضخم اقرت الحكومه الاردنيه حزمه
من الاجراءات كرفع نسبه الفائده ومنع
تصدير المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه وزياده
مراقبه الاسواق
[موسيقى]
مصمم جرافيكي خلال التضخم اللي صار عندنا
في البلد يعني اثر عليه بشكل شخص وعلى
عائلته مثلا كونان
المبلغ 20 او 30 دينار بدك تشتري فيه كم
من غرض يعني انت بحاجتهم الان اصبح ب20
و30 دينار ما بيجيبوا لك هذه الاغراض صار
الرقم مضاعف يعني مرات متاخر بشغل يعني لا
منتصف الليل حتى انت بشكل اكبر وهمم من
الامور الترفيه اللي كنت يعني انا يعني ما
منها لعائلتي يعني
لما نحكي عن الاردن كمشهد مرتبط بتضخم
لعمل ماضي كان 1.3 الان 2.4 العمله
الاردنيه بماذا مرتبطه مرتبطه بالدولار
الامريكي ولكن احنا عندنا مشكله برفع
تكلفه اسعار المواد الخام الاوليه زادت
اسعار النفط اذا زادت اسعار تكاليف الشحن
بدن نحن نتحدث عن زياده اسعار البضائع رغم
انه احنا اقرا يعني اعتمادنا عليها في
المواد الغذائيه يعني نسبه قليله ما
تاثرنا فيها ولكن احنا تاثرنا بالمعادن
يعني الاسمده الان اللي هي مرتبطه بالزرع
على دينه هاي اثرت لدينا على الامن
الغذائي اثرت على اسعار الغذاء اثرت على
اسعار الخضار والفواكه
احنا كده مستوردين او كانه مستخدم مواد
خام في المواد الورقيه والبلاستيكيه
والمقطعيه يعني ارتفع عندنا الاستيراد
لاكثر 100% يعني اللي كنا نستوردوا بالف
دينار على سبيل المثال صار يكلفنا ال
2,000 دينار هذا كشحن كمواد خام او كماد
اولي نفس الشيء هذا بالتالي الا من نسبه
ربحي وانعكس عندي حتى في داخل سوريا يعني
داخل المنشاه يعني انا عندي موظفين يعني
هذا الموظف برضه تضخم اثر عليه فبالتالي
هو بده اصلا راتب اكبر
[موسيقى]
احد حلول التضخم وزياده الاسعار انه احنا
نقلل الضريبه اللي هي بتكون 16% او 8% ل
4% الى 0%
في الولايات المتحده اكبر اقتصادات العالم
سجل معدل التضخم ارتفاعا بنسبه
8.5% في شهر مارس 2022 وهي الاعلى منذ عام
1981 بحسب ارقام وزاره العمل الامريكيه ما
خلق تاثيرات سلبيه في الاقتصاد الامريكي
واقتصادات الدول المرتبطه به وبعملته
الصعبه التضخم في امريكا تجلى بارتفاع
اسعار العقارات والسلع الاساسيه واسعار
الطاقه
مرحبا انا اتصل بكم بخصوص فاتوره الغاز
الاخيره لاستفسر منكم لماذا هي مرتفعه جدا
الى الحوافز الكبيره التي ضختها الحكومه
الامريكيه في نظامها المالي خلال ازمه
كورونا اضافه الى خفض سعر الفائده وفي
محاوله منه لاحتواء هذا التضخم الى ما دون
اثنين بالمئه اطلق البنك الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي حزمه من السياسات النقديه كان
اخرها رفع معدل الفائده بمقدار ربع مئويه
اني
الولايات المتحده لاننا لم نشهد تضخما منذ
ثمانينيات القرن العشرين ولكننا نواجهه
الان بطريقه جديده في بلادنا يميل التضخم
الى الانتشار في جميع مجالات الاقتصاد لان
كل شيء مرتبط ببعضه من خلال نظام السوق
نرى الان التضخم مرتفع بشكل خاص في اسعار
الطاقه لان المعروضه من الوقود قد تباطا
السلع الزراعيه ايضا تصبح اكثر تكلفه بسبب
الجفاف في كاليفورنيا
بسبب نقص العماله كما ارتفعت في اجزاء
اخرى من العالم بسبب الاضطرابات في
اوكرانيا
ايه
انا مدرسه تربيه خاصه ادريس منذ سته سنوات
وانا الان في مرحله تغيير مهنتي لانني
اريد جني المزيد من المال فحسب التضخم
الثرى علي وعلى حياتي خصوصا الاشهر
الماضيه لاحظت ارتفاع اسعار الوقود اسعار
البقاله ارتفعت فواتير ارتفع ثمن طعام كلب
اجتماعيا تغيرت حياتي احاول تناول الطعام
من منزل دائما بدات في زراعه الخضروات
والاعشاب واشياء من هذا القبيل لتوفير بعض
المال لقد قللت من تناول اللحوم لانها
باهظه الثمن
[موسيقى]
الحكومه تحاول الان جاهزه للحد من التضخم
الذي نشعر به هنا الشيء الوحيد الذي
يمكنهم فعله هو ابطاؤ الاقتصاد وهو ما
تحاول الحكومه اجراءه عبر الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي من خلال زياده اسعار الفائده
ولكن هذا امر مؤلم للغايه وغير مرضى من
الناحيه السياسيه لذا فان الحكومه تعمل
جاهده لمواجهه الازمه بالتزامن مع محاوله
الحفاظ على النمو الاقتصادي
قعده ما تلجا الاقتصادات الكبرى لسياسات
النقديه لترويض معدلات التضخم عبر تغيير
سعر الفائده وهذا ما ساعد كل من نيوزلندا
وكندا والمملكه المتحده باحتواء التضخم في
ثمانينيات القرن الماضي لكن الارتفاع
الحاليه في معدلات التضخم والذي طال كل
القطاعات الاقتصاديه تقريبا جعل رفع سعر
الفائده حلا غير كاف بحسب خبراء اقتصاديين
امريكيين والذين دعوا لوقف الانفاق وتجميد
الحرب التجاريه مع الصين ومكافحه الاحتكار
وزياده الانتاج كما فعلت المانيا عقب
الحرب العالميه
بالطبع لا يوجد وصفه جاهزه لحاله تضخم
يمكن ان نطبقها على كل دول العالم فكل
دوله لها خصوصيه داخليه من ناحيه الانشطه
الاقتصاديه من ناحيه عجز الميزان التجاري
من ناحيه عدد السكان ولكن هناك نماذج
بالفعل على ارض الواقع نجحت في مواجهه هذا
التضخم على سبيل المثال التضخم الكبير
الذي عانت منه كل دول امريكا اللاتينيه
البرازيل والارجنتين ولكن كانت هناك كلمه
سر اساسيه تنشيط النمو تنشيط الانتاج
المحلي
ثنتينر ايه
اذا استمر هذا لفتره طويله من الوقت فان
توقعات الناس ستكون ان الاسعار سترتفع ثم
سيبداون في التصرف مع هذا التوقع الذي
سيفاقم التضخم ويجعل من الصعب محاربته
وانهائه هذه مشكله كبيره للحكومات بمجرد
ان يبدا التضخم فمن الصعب للغايه وايقافه
في ظل تفاقم ازمه التضخم عالميا وما قد
يرافقها من ارتفاع في معدلات الفقر
والجريمه يبرز التساؤل حول مدى خطوره
اثاره فليشهد العالم كسادا اشبه بكساد عام
1929 الذي كان احد اسباب اندلاع الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ان تنجح الحكومات
العالميه والعربيه بتحصين مواطنها
واسواقها عبر حلول جديده
وبينما تترقبوا منطقتنا والعالم الاجابه
عن السؤال الختامي لقصتنا عن خطوره اثار
التضخم بين صندوق النقد الدولي يرسم
سيناريو قاتما للاقتصاد العالمي خلال عام
2023 وذلك في ظل تباط
ئ النفاذه لمحركات نمو العالمي
الرئيسي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واوروبا والصين ومعدلات تضخم عالميه بلغت
مستويات غير مسبوقه منذ عقود وحذرت
كريستالينا جورجينا وهي مديره صندوق النقد
الدولي من ان الثلث الاقتصاد العالمي
سيتعرض لحاله ركودا خلالها هذا العام
وتضاعف معدل التضخم عام 2000
ليصلها الى حدود تسعه في المئه عالميا
وذلك بعد ان كان 74% خلال 2000 وواحد 2020
توقع صندوق النقد الدولي ان تبلغ نسبه
التضخم سته ونصف في المئه خلال هذا العام
وانت تراجع في العام المقبل الى حدود
اربعه في المئه تنبا الصندوق بتراجع معدل
النمو العالم هذا العام الى اثنين وسبعه
اعشار فيلم بعد ان كان سته في المئه كمان
يشاهد وذلك عام
2021 رغم تفاؤل ببعض مؤشرات اداء الاقتصاد
الامريكي الجيده فان التق ابعث لي معدل
النمو لاكبر اقتصاد العالمي جاءت متشائمه
اذا يبلغ واحدا في المائه فقط هذا العام
بعد ما وصل الى نحو 6% وذلك في العام
المنصرم اما بالنسبه للصين وهي ثاني اكبر
اقتصاده عالمي فالتوقعات تتنبا بنسب نمو
تتجاوز الارض في المئه لهذا العام بعد ان
سجلت نموا باكثر من ثمانيه في المئه وذلك
في العام المنصرم التراجع الاكبر لمعدلات
النمو المتوقعه سيكون من نصيب منطقه
اليورو اذ قدرت نسبه النمو المتوقعه هذا
العام بنصف في المئه فقط وقد كان النمو في
منطقه اليورو قد سجل اكثر من خمسه في
المئه خلال العام الماضي ومن المتوقع ان
تشهد اقتصاداته المنطقه العربيه نمونا
بنسبه 54 في المئه في هذا العام لكن هذا
النمو سينخفض الى اكثر من ثلاثه في المئه
وذلك في العام المقبله وكان قد سجل 5%
العام الماضي وقد ارتفعت مستويات الفقر في
المنطقه العربيه لتصل الى 30% من السكان
لدى الارتفاع التضخم الذي وصل معدله الى
14% العمل الماضيه
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مجددا المشاهدين
من عمان الدكتور جواد العناني نائب رئيس
الوزراء الاردني السابق لشؤون الاقتصاديه
ومن انتاريو مصطفى يوسف الباحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي مدير المركز الدولي
للدراسات التنمويه والاستراتيجيه اهلا
بضيفين الكريمين لعلنا نبدا معك دكتور
جواد العناني بين النظريه المؤامره التي
تقول بان ازمه التضخم العالميه ليست سوى
ازمه مفتله وذلك في اطار صراع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مع قوتين اخرىين هما
الصين من جهه وروسيا من جهه اخرى وذلك
للفرد وبسيطرتها وصدارتها في النظام
العالمي الحالي وبين من يقول ويرجعها
لمؤشرات الاقتصاد التي تربطها مباشره
بالحروب
المشاكل او حتى
السياسات النقديه وغيرها من الامور ما
الذي تقوله كخبير في هذا الموضوع في ما
يخص جذور هذه الازمه ازمه التضخم
جذور الازمه بدات عندما بدانا
نطبق قواعد بتخفيض اسعار الفائده على
الدولار حتى وصلت صفرا ولذلك تازمت في
الولايات المتحده ازمه المديونيه ليس فقط
المديونيه الخارجيه
والمديونيه التي تاخذ الولايات المتحده من
دول اخرى عن طريق طباعتها لكميات كبيره من
الدولارات ولكن ايضا بسبب
انخفاض اسعار الفائده في الداخل اغرى
كثيرا من المشتركين بالاقتراب فلذلك نرى
كنا بانه ال- ال- القطاع الخاص الامريكي
مدين الى البنوك بحواره 19 مليون دولار
هذه الارقام الكبيره جدا والتي تكادته
تساوي الناتج المحلي الاجمالي الامريكي
همم ليست مسبقه
وجاءت بعد ذلك اداره الرئيس بايدن في
بدايتها في عام 2000 يعني في عام 2020
لتقول ال 21
بتقرب برنامج كبيرا جدا للانفاق طبعا
سياتي عن ماذا سياتي عن طريق اما زياده
الضرائب من ناحيه او بالاكثر هي عن طريق
طباعه النقود لاصلاح البنى التحتيه وغيرها
وفوجئ العالم ايضا بان الكرونه اولا سببت
تقطعا في سلاسل التجويد العالم كان يعتمد
الى حد كبير على فائض الانتاج الصيني
والذي كان يباع نسبيا بارخاص باسعار
معقوله والصين قررت بعد فتره ان استمرارها
في انتاج السلع الاستهلاكيه ليس هو
المستقبل لها ولذلك في المؤتمر الحزب
الشيوعي قررت ان تتحول الى ما يسمى بانتاج
السلع ذات المحتوى التكنولوجيا العالي
وبدات تتنوع وتريد ايضا هي عن طريق مؤسسات
مثل علاء الدين ان تسوي هي بضائها لا ان
تبيعها الى شركات امريكيه واوروبيه تعيد
تغليفها وتسميتها
وعدد ريبراندم يعني يسموها اعاده
تسميتها باسماء براقه وتبيعها باضعف
الاسعار تريد ان تشارك ايضا في هذه
الارباح كل هذه العوامل اجتمعت مع بعضها
البعض وانتقلت الى باقي اقتصادي العالم
لما اتت بعد ذلك حرب اوكرانيا اثرت على
السلعه الرئيسيه الاساسيه اللي هي النفط
والغاز والمواد الغذائيه خاصه القمح وعباد
الشمس بسيطه
هي انه معظم مبيعات العالم في السلع
الغذائيه تحتكر حوالي خمس او ست شركات
اسريه هذه الشركات مستفيده عند الشراء
ومستفيده عند البيع وهذه حققت ارباح
الكبيره جدا استثمرت الفرصه في تقطع ال ال
هذه فلذلك في نوع من اليه السوق
واحتكاريتها التي ساهمت في رفع الاسعار
خاصه على الدول الناميه والدول المستورده
وارجعته لعوامل الاقتصاديه والسياسات
اقتصاديه
لجائزه كورونا ايضا وايضا تحدثت عن الحرب
الاوكرانيه اتحول للدكتور مصطفى يوسف لا
احد ينكر ان القلاقل والمشاكل السياسيه
والحروب لها تاثير كبير همم على همم
الموضوع همم الاقتصادي وراينا كيف حدث ذلك
فيما خص الحرب الاوكرانيه وقد اشار اليه
جواد
باعتقادك اذا ما هادات الامور اذا تم اذا
ما تم التوصل لتسويات نتحدث عن حرب
اوكرانيا انت وقفت هذه الحرب نتحدث ايضا
عن التوترات الموجوده ما بين الولايات
المتحده وهي اكبر اقتصاد وثاني اقتصاد
عالمي وهي الصين في ما يخص تايوان او حتى
المحيط الهادئ باعتقادك هل يمكن ان يؤثر
ذلك على معدلات التضخم في الامد القريب في
العام الحالي
الان نحن امام ظاهره يعني غير مسبوقه همم
وان كنت يعني ارجع اسبابها الى 1972 حاليا
حينما قمر الرئيس
يعني كان يستطيع اي انسان او دوله استبدال
اقيس الذهب ب 35 دولار امريكي ثم ارتفع ل
38 ونصف دولار امريكي الان وهي اصبحت
الولايات المتحده تطبع دولارات لاي يعني
ظروف يمر بهذا الاقتصاد الامريكي واصبحت
اداء من ادوات الامريكيه اذا تم التفاهمات
وتم الاستماع لصوت العقل واداره الصراع مع
روسيا وقبول الاداره الامريكيه بان العالم
اصبح متعوده همم
كثيرا معدله للتضخم نحن الان همم يعني ما
يعني لدينا عنصران كبيرا في ارتفاع اسعار
التضخم وتدهور همم يعني معيشه الكثير من
الناس والان لدينا اكثر من مليار شخصي
يريد جائعا في هذا العالم في منطقه في
المنطقه العربيه اكثر من 30% من العرب
حوالي 150 مليون تقريبا يعانون من الجوع
نتيجه هذه
الازدياد الكبير بسعر الطاقه اولا ثم
ازدياد الكبير في سعر المواد الغذائيه
وسلاسل الامداد والتوليد اصبح التضخم الان
تضخم ناجم عن ازدياد كل
الانتاج اصبحت هناك في الاسعار
الموقف يعني لو تم هل حاله الازمه ما بين
امريكا والصين
والتقدير التوترات في جنوب بحر الصين
بخصوص سيوان ثم ثم يعني الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هناك تفاهمات حادثه برعايه
اماميه ورعايه تركيا تم من خلالها تصدير
الحبوب والاسمده والزيوت لو يعني يعني
تخصصت تركيا وهي تتمتع باحترام الجانبيه
بين الاوروبيين والام كان لان تركيا عضو
في حلف الناتو وكذلك الكريملين الرئيس
بوتين بيقدر الاداره التركيه لو تم
الاستماع الى صوت العقل وتم يعني نوع من
انواع التهدئه سينعكس ذلك ايجابيا على
انخفاض اسعار التضم ولكن يعني الان نفتش
عن من هو المستفيد من يعني مد امد هذه
الحرب العباسيه بين روسيا واوكرانيا وهم
تمام ينتميان بنفس العرق بل هو نفس
الكنيسه يعني الان شركات السلاح شركات
البترول الكبرى يعني الشركات الاربعه
الذين ورد في الاخوات السبعه اكس مابل
وشيفرون وبي بي بي وريال باتشان يستفيدون
من ارتفاع اسعار البترول شركات والمؤسسات
الماليه يعني يعني اكثر من 60% من اموال
هذا الكوكب يتم تداولها في المربع الصغير
في منهاتن واقول الصيد حينما تزداد اسعار
الفائده وهو امر نعيم للغايه لان العنصر
الرئيسي لزياده التضخم في العالم هو
ازدياد سوريا يعني الاسعار الفائده وزياده
كلفه الاقرار كيف يستطيع اي شركه صغيره او
اي يعني رائد اعمال ان ينتج ويعين يعني
يقلل من البطاله الموجوده مع ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده يعني في امريكا الان 24% ومن
المتوقع في البدايات شبراير
ساعود اليك دكتور مصطفى اتحول مره اخرى
دكتور جواد يعني في كل مره يعود الموضوع
الصين لا شك بان همم بعض عوامل تضخم
ومشاكل سلاسل توريد العالميه تعود مباشره
الى همم الصين وهي اكبر دوله مصدره في
العالم كما يعلم الجميع هناك توقعات بنمو
اكثر من اربعه في المئه في الصين كيف
سيؤثر ذلك باعتقادك ونحن نعلم انه اذا زاد
النمو يقل التضخم كيف سيؤثر ذلك على الوضع
العالمي في ظل تباطؤ النمو الامريكي
واوروبا القاره العجوز كما تبعنا في
الميناء الليله هي الاكثر همم تاثرا
وتضررا من هذه الازمات
طبعا اوروبا واضح لاسباب انها محتاجه الى
النفط والغاز الذي ليس لديها ولذلك تدفع
عليها الاسعار الكلف كثيرا جدا وفي نفس
الوقت تعاني من تضخم وتعاني ايضا من تباطه
في الانتاج سبب نقص الصادرات العالميه في
ظل الازمه ازمه القران في ظل الحرب ايضا
لذلك عانت اوروبا من جانبين وارتفاع الكره
عليها من ناحيه ونقص الطلب على بضائها من
ناحيه اخرى
كذلك نرى ان الصين عوده الى سؤالك عن
الصين الصين اخذت قرارا قبل همم يومين
بفتح عدودها في هذه المباراه
كبيره نعم ولذلك لما كانت مغلقه الصين كان
عليها ضغط من الولايات المتحده وغيرها بان
تفتح لما فتحت قالوا بانك فتحت ولذلك زادت
عندك الحالات وانت الان نريد منك شفافيه
عن عدد الحالات حتى لا يصاب العالم بالاخر
الصين قررت في نهايه الامر انها يجب ان
تتخلى عن سياسه تصفير حالات الكرونه خاصه
لانه حاله الوفاه قليله جدا لذلك قالت
فليصب الناس بالتدريجيا بتخف العدوى كما
حصل في كثير من دول العالم في في عام 201
في تخفيف الازمه من ناحيه ولكنهم من ناحيه
اخرى ايضا سوف يزيد الاستهلاك الصيني نفسه
على هذه السلع يعني بمعنى ان الصينيين همم
الطبقه المتوسطه ستزداد الطالب في داخل
الصين سوف يزداد ولذلك لن يكون ال-
الفائده ال- ال- ال- ال- النهائي من هذا
الامر لصالح الاقتصادي العالمي لذلك على
الدول اا كثير من الدول ان تبدا في
التفكير كيف تحل مشاكلها على الاقل ضمن
التفاهمات الاقليميه همم حتى لا تنفرد
دوله بحل كل المشكلات التي قد تفوق قدرتها
على حلها ولذلك نحن يعني يجب ان ندعو
العالم العربي الى بناء ما يسمى تفاهماته
اقليميه تساعد الدول تساعد بعضها البعض
على تجاوز هذه الايه
لكنه ود ان نفهم الصوره الاجماليه
للاقتصاد العالمي تحدثنا عن الاقتصاد
الاول في العالم الامريكي تحدثنا عن الصين
وهي ثاني اقتصاد في العالم لكن ماذا عن
الاقتصاد الثالث في العالم والحديث عن
اليابان وسؤال للدكتور مصطفى
واليابان سلكت اتجاها محاكسا تماما لمن
رفع سعر الفائده هي ثبت سعر الفائده كيف
يمكن تقييم هذا السعر الذي همم
يتخذه السياسيون في اليابان وانعكاساته
على اقتصادها كيف تراه
يعني ما تقوم به الاداره في اليابان هو
يعني همم اتباع الاقتصاد الكندي وهو الحل
الامثل والانجا لان يعني ازدياد سعر
الفائده همم سيؤدي الى زياده كلفه الاقراض
وزياده اسعار السلع وزياده مؤشر
المستهلكين وهذا ما لا تريد الحكومه
اليابانيه يعني اليابان تنتهج نهج يعني
التجارب التنمويه حينما ندرس بعض التجارب
الثانيه
همم يعني الولد الاولى همم عكس ما
يشير به صندوق النقل الدولي والبنك الدولي
برفع سعر الفائده همم سعر الفائده هو ال-
المكون الرئيسي
للتضخم ولا ازدياد الاسعار ولاخراج كثير
من الشركات التي لا تستطيع ان تقابل تكلفه
الاقرار
ما يقوم به اليابان همم حكومه وشعبا همم
ينم عن همم عمق وثقافه متجزره لا تقبل
اطلاقا ان تستورد التضخم وتجعل المنتجين
يتحملون جزءا كبيرا من التضخم مع المستهلك
هذا عن اليابان دكتور مصطفى فقد حتى يعني
نتقدم قليلا في النقاش اوروبا القاره
العجوز كما ذكرنا تبدو اكثر واكبر
المتضررين في هذه الازمه ما بدائل المتاحه
لهم باعتقادك للخروج من هذه الازمه وحتى
يعني امورهم في خلال هذا العام الذي يبدو
انه سيكون عاما عصيبا على القاره
الاوروبيه ودول الاتحاد الاوروبيه
هل اوروبا ليس لديها الى الحله واحده
المشكله عروسه بس يا بلد كبير تمت اداره
الصراع مع روسيا اداره خاطئه رغم غدا
اخلاقيه العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
ولكن ليس لكل هذه العقوبات غير المسبوقه
العقوبات التي فرضها الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده على روسيا كانت اشبه من
يطلق النار على قدميه يعني الان اسعار
الغاز تتضاعفه اربع مرات المستفاد من ذلك
شركات الغاز المسال الامريكي من الذي تضرب
الاوروبيين اكثر بكثير من الرسول نعم
الاوروبيين من ناحيه الجنسيه والامريكان
يريدون ان يمتد امل الحرب حتى يتم استهلاك
الاحتياطي الكبير الذي يعني ركماته روسيه
في العقد الاخير وهو اكثر من 643 مليار
دولار ولكن هذا امر يوجد الان الرئيس لديه
ميونخ قوميه شديده يحاول اعاده امجاد يعني
روسيا القديمه ولم يفرق في امره القومي
وال يعني عدم الالتزام بالتفاهنات بعد
امتداد 1,000 جنيه 2 الى اوكرانيا من قبل
الاوروبيين الامريكان انعكست على يعني
الوضع اقتصادي مزرين في اوروبا وينبغي ان
تخلخل هذه المشكله اعد مره اخرى للدكتور
جواد العناني اقعد معك للنقل التي كنت قد
اثرتها عن الدول العربيه ونتساءل حقيقه عن
بعضها يعني نحن في العالم العربي كيف اثرت
موجه التضخم العالمي على المنطقه ودول
العالم العربي النفطيه وغير النفطيه
الحقيقه ان هناك تفاوت كبير في تاثير
الازمات على الدول العربيه لانه هنالك عده
حالات مختلفه مثلا عندما تنظرين
الاقتصادات التي كانت تعاني اصلا بسبب
الحروب الداخليه والفتن وغيرها هي التي
عانت اكثر من غيرها يعني لبنان سوريا
العراق حتى نجد ان عملتها قد تراجعت كثيرا
صار الصرف فيها قد ترد وانه حتى في لبنان
الان نتكلم على الدولار يساوي 40 الف ليره
لبنانيه يعني بمعنى انه لو في عندك فئه
المئه ليره او ال 1000 ليره معنى هذه هذه
لا تساوي كل في الطباعتها يعني قوتها
الشرائيه لا تكاد تساوي كلفه الورق والحبر
الذي ينفقه عليها لطباعتها هذه الحقيقه
قضيه صعبه جدا لانك بنشوف انه معدلات
التضخم في هذه الدول هذا اذا في ارقام
موثوقه نعم
كثيرا العراق حسب ما يقول رئيس الوزراء
العراقي بانه كمان هنالك تراجع في قيمه
همم الدينار العراقي والقوه الشرائيه
والعراق حتى الان لا تستطيع وضع موازنه
بشكل واضح اللي ترسم سياساتها كذلك نرى
الامر في سوريا ايضا رسول الله
انها تستطيع تعويضه نفسها بسبب ارتفاع
اسعار
ولذلك عوضت نفسه عن هذا ترى انه يمكن اذا
قالوا انه في هنالك الدول المستفيده كثيرا
من الوضع وهم غير قاصدين يعني غير مقصودين
كانت الدول الدول الخليج همم مستفيد
الاكبر
يعني رغم ذلك
صندوق النقد الدوليه توقع تباط ان في نمو
الاقتصاد في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وارتفاعا
للتدخل في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وهذه كل المنطقه التي تقع ضمنها
الدول العربيه في ضوء هذا ما التحديات
باعتقادك التي تواجه الدول العربيه خلال
هذا العام
مبدئيا يعني ينبغي على الدول العربيه ان
يتم مكافحه الفساد استخدام الموارد
الموجوده لاستخدام الامثل وعمل خطط تنويه
يعني يتم التنميه في الانسان وليست تنميه
الطرق او الحجر
تجارب التنميه ماليزيا سنغافوره برازيل
تركيا اعتمدت على ان يكون الانسان منتجا
يتم تحقيق خطط من الاكتفاء الذاتي في
الطعام وضع تركيا الان قويه لانها اكتفتيا
بنسبه كبيره من الغذاء ومن السلاح ومن
الادويه الان سنغافوره نفس الموضوع
ماليزيا كانت في اثناء ولايه مهاتير محمد
وده اكثر من 20 عاما نفس الوضع الدول
العربيه الان لدينا بعض البشائر من كتب
التنمويه جيده للغايه في المغرب لان مشاعر
اخرى للمكافحه الفساد باسترداد للاموال
المنهوبه في الجزائر نتمنى من باقي الدول
ان يتم بعض المصالحه المجتمعيه يتم
استخدام الموارد الموجوده في الدول
العربيه الاستخدام الامثل لدعم السيارات
الصغيره ودعم الانسان والصحه والتعليم حتى
يمكن الانفاق بشكل كبير على خطط تنميه
وليس الانفاق على بعض المشروعات غير ذات
الجدول اقتصاديه حتى تتمكن هذه الدول من
عبور ازمه تكاد تكون الاكبر في التاريخ
الحديث للدول العربيه اما الدكتور جواد
يعني تحدث عن العلم العربي والتحديات التي
تواجهها وشاهدنا في قصتنا تاثير التضخم
عفوا على ارتفاع اسعار الخامات كالاسمده
التي تدخل في همم الزراعه راينا قصصا يعني
مؤثره لمزارعين سواء في همم السودان همم
كما تابعنا في فيلم الليله وهذه امثله فقط
شاهدنا امثله في السودان والاردن لكن
الامثله عديده على امتداد العالم العربي
للاسف والسؤال في في الواقع العالم العربي
بتنوع هذه الموارد الموجوده لديه لماذا
يتحسب لمثل هذا ولا نريد ان نتحذر ماذا
يمكن ان نفعل الان قد جهود فرديه او حتى
كجهود جماعيه لما لا لمواجهه هذه الازمه
اعتقادك
اعتقد على مستوى الموارد فورا يجب ان نبدا
بتطوير همم
منظومه واحده هي منظومه الطاقه والمياه
والزراعه والامن الغذائي هذه منظومه
اساسيه جدا لانها متكامله مع بعضها البعض
ومعنى اننا من الان فصاعدا حتى نزيد من
كميات المياه التي تفتقر كثير من الدول
العربيه اليها او مهدده بضياع مواردها
الاساسيه هي ان تجد وسائل لزياده المياه
عن طريق الطاقه
ولذلك تدخل الطاقه عنصر الاساسي توفير
المياه واذا توفرت المياه يصبح ايضا
امكانيه التوسع في انتاج الغذاء اكثر
بكثير وطبعا هذا الطلب ادخال التكنولوجيا
وادخال وسائل حديثه على الزراعه والتدريب
القوه البشريه تدريبا صعب اذا منظومه
الثلاثيه هذه الضروريه جدا النقطه الثانيه
الحقيقه في رايي والانتقال نحو التصنيع
والتصنيع الغذائي والتصنيع الادويه
الدوائي وتسجيع التعامل العربي العربي في
هذا المجال
وتخصيص مبالغ من اجل البحث على البحث
والتطوير يعني انا بعتقد انه اذا اكتفينا
غذائيا واكتفينا
واكتفينا من حيث الابديه كما ذكر زميل
الضيف في هذه الحلقه الدكتور انا بعتقد
انه بيكون قطعنا شرطا كبيرا نحو ما يسمى
تحصين انفسنا من ان نكون يعني معرضين
لهشاشه همم هشاشه الموقف الذي قد يفرض
علينا اذا تامرت علينا الدول همم الخارجيه
همم يعني هذه امور بحسنها سابقا ويجب ان
نعطيها من الجديه لم تعد للبحث فيها مجرد
رفاهيه فلا اصبحت ضروره قسوه وعلينا ان
نتكامل في مواردنا ونوفر هذه الامور همم
لابنائنا في المستقبل الخاصه وان في بعض
الدول فيها مجاعات ولو الفقر ليست قضيه
فقط 30% انما نحن نع ارتفاع نسب الفقر
المدقع الفقر الذي لا يستطيع الانسان في
ان يسمى به للاسف الشديد ونرى ذلك للاسف
في البلدان العربيه عديده دكتور جواد
دكتور مصطفى من كلام الدكتور جواد ما الذي
نستشفه هذا الفقر المدقع كيف اثر على فئات
المجتمع الاكثر هشاشه بدايه
وفيما اثر فيهم ما السلع التي تضررت اكثر
بهذا الارتفاع الجنوبي في الاسعار الذي
كان سببه الاول هذا همم التضخم
يعني هناك العديد من الناس الان يعانون
معنا شديده جدا في ان يبيتون يعني يعني
يعني الرقم قبل قبل النوم يعني الان نحن
امام يعني ظاهره انسانيه مفجره
ينبغي على يعني على الشق الاجتماعي ان
تتكاثف يعني الدول مع بعضها البعض وداخل
الدوله
حتى يتم يعني
مساعده منهم اكثر احتياجا وشق على مستوى
كل دوله ااه ان يتم استخدام الموارد
الاستخدام الانفال واستخدام فوائد الاموال
الدول التي استفادت دون قصد منها الدول
الافريقيه التي لديها فوائد كبيره من
الغاز ان تستثمر هذه الاموال في يعني ما
يحقق ويكفل هل يعني الاكتفاء من الغذاء
والاكتفاء من التصنيع حتى يتم تقليل
التضخم المستورد الذي ياتي الينا ويستفيد
منه فقط يعني المؤسسه الماليه ومعتمرات
الغرب وشركات البترول الكبرى همم تستفيد
من ذلك ونعاني نحن همم ولكن ذلك يقتضي
وجود خطب تنمويه همم لكل دوله او خطب
تكامليه بين الدول العربيه لكل دوله لها
بعض المزايا النسبيه ولابد ان تتكامل هذه
الدول حتى لا نعاني مستقبلا من اي
قبره مثل التي يمر بها الاهل اكثر من ايه
ازمه كبرى وهي اقتصاديه هناك الثمن ايضا ل
همم هذا هذه الازمات الاقتصاديه راينا ذلك
غير بعيد او حتى بعيد في ديمقراطيات لم
تعد ذلك راينا همم اضطرابات في بريطانيا
مؤشرات احتجاجيه في دول اوروبيه اخرى
والعالم العربي الى طالما معنا ولا طالما
تحركت هذه الشعوب مطالبه بالحريه نعم لكن
كان ما يحركها ايضا هو لقمه العيش ايضا
وبالتالي سؤالي للدكتور جواد العناني ما
همم الثمن باعتقادك لاستمرار ارتفاع
معدلات التضخم الذي يمكن ان تدفعها هذه
الدول العربيه ان هي لم يعني همم تقوم
بمواجهه هذا الموضوع تصدي له بكل جديديه
قطع تستمر حاله الفوضى وحاله التوكل يعني
هذا امر واضح يعني اذا وصلت الامور الى ان
ابن يخرج صباحا من البيت ليبحث عن عمل
ويبحث عن مصدر رزق وينتظره اولاده في
البيت يعود اليهم خاوي الوفاء وبدون اي
طعام اعتقد انه لا تراه لا شيء يقضوا
كرامه الانسان اكثر من هذا المشهد فلذلك
علينا ان نقول ان نكون ندرك بان حل
المشكله الاقتصاديه لا يكمن فقط عند
الاقتصاديين وانما عن تداخل المعارف يعني
لابد لنا ان ندخل الاجتماعيين وعلماء
سياسه ان يدخل ايضا علماء النفس وغيرهم
حتى تتكامل الصوره ونخرج بحلول الانسانيه
نعم طبعا والاراده السياسيه تاتي قبل كل
هذا وان يكون في هنالك تعاطف مع المواطن
وادراك وشعور بانه يستطيع ان يثق
بالمعلومات التي تؤدي تعطى اليه وانه
يستطيع ان يركن الى ان القرارات التي تؤخذ
سوف تجد طريقها الى التنفيذ وان الدول
العربيه التي صار احيانا على اشياء بسيطه
جدا وتقاطع بعضها البعض عليها ان تتخلى عن
كل هذه السياسات وان تنتبه الى ان موجوده
الى نفسه مهدد اذا هي لم تنتبه الى اهميه
همم مراعاه شعوبها واخذ مصالح يا بعين
ضيفنا من عمان الدكتور جواد العناني نائب
رئيس الوزراء الاردني السابق لشؤون
الاقتصاديه كما اشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفنا
الدكتور مصطفى يونس او عفوا مصطفى يوسف
الباحث في الاقتصاد السياسي مدير المركز
الدولي لدراسات التنمويه والاستراتيجيه
ختمه حلقتنا هذه من برنامج في القصه بقيه
نعود ونلقاكم باذن الله مع بقيه لقصه
جديده الاثنين القادم السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]